this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out the game through the link in the
description below go through that link
and you'll not only support this show be
also get a free premium tank or aircraft
and three days of premium time as a
bonus and let's get into app actually
before we get into it I just want to say
that there are French pronunciations in
this one
indeed the man's name himself shall do
gol that's I believe how you pronounce
it in French I'm gonna go with the
accepted English pronunciation of
Charles de Gaulle because it's easier
for me unless like to destroy it up
there's also other French pronunciations
if you don't like it deal with it or
just have a go at me in the comments
below I'm not gonna read them Charles de
Gaulle was the sort of man who turned
heads at 6 foot 5 inches in height he
towered over his contemporaries and
with his regal bearing and firm gaze he
exuded an air of forth right
self-confidence throughout his life his
unswerving love for France coupled with
his determination to right the wrongs of
the past turned him into a hero of the
resistance movement and one of the
French Republic's truly great statesman
in today's by graphics we examine the
very full life of Charles de Gaulle
Charles Andre Joseph Marie de Gaulle was
born on November the 22nd 1890 he was
the third of five children to Henri and
jean de Gaulle honoré was a military man
who had served in the franco-prussian
war by the time his second son was born
he was a teacher at a Catholic school in
the French industrial region of Lille
shortly after the birth of Charles the
family moved to Paris where on Rita got
the position as the headmaster of the
Jesuit college of the Immaculate
Conception Andre was a lover of history
and the glory of France Knights in the
de Gaulle home would often be spent with
the children gathered around to listen
to their father
regale them with stories of the
country's history and the past their
ancestors had played in it Charles would
later recall the stories his father
would tell them about their most famous
ancestor celia hunter Ghul knight who
fought against the English at the Battle
of Agincourt
the glorious history of his nation that
Charles was learning at the feet of his
father came with a distrust of the
country's natural enemy of the British
honor II would not allow his children to
learn the English language
Charles his mother Jean loved her
country more than a husband Charles
would later say that she had an
uncompromising love for her country that
was equal to her religious piety the
defeat of France of the Battle of Sudan
in 1870 during the franco-prussian war
was a source of humiliation for all
French Patriots including the de
gaulle's
they sieved with the desire to avenge
the shame that had fallen upon their
once mighty nation they kept this
ambition alive in their children with
honour irregularly taken them to the
cemetery at La Baule and having them
read aloud the inscription to the dead
of 1870 the sword of France broken in
their valiant hands will once more be
reformed by their descendants even
though he wasn't the smartest of the
five de gold children Charles was their
natural leader
he had a mischievous dominant attitude
and he was always organizing some sort
of practical joke on one of his siblings
when he was about six he invented his
own language which involved speaking
French backwards he forced his brothers
and sisters to learn it they naturally
objected was his insistence paid off and
they all became fluent at it this was an
early sign of the determination and
persistent force of character that would
come to be a trademark of Charles as an
adult
[Music]
like most French boy is Charles love to
play soldiers yet when he and his
brothers lined up their model armies on
the bedroom floor he would exhibit a
seriousness and intensity than 20 on a
childhood game he always insisted on
portraying the French army and would
become cold and dispassionate during the
war games as he put his total energies
into defeating the enemy
Charles attended the Jesuit college
where his father was the headmaster he
was a keen students who loved to read
and developed an early interest in
philosophy by the age of 10 though he
had decided that he was going to pursue
a life in the military from that point
onward Charles was single-minded in his
military focus at the age of 15 he wrote
an essay in which he projected himself
forward to the year 1930 where as
General de Gaulle he led the French army
in defeating the Germans finally
inflicting vengeance for the defeat of
1870 Charles was determined to win a
place at the military academy at socia
his hard work at school it paid off and
he was accepted into the Academy in 1909
however prospective officers were
required to serve a year in the ranks
before entering Officer Training School
and so in October of 1909 he was
enlisted into the 33rd Infantry Regiment
stationed at her ass for months later he
won his first promotion to corporal it
was usual for an aspiring officer to
reach the rank of sergeant during the
first year but the Gould's company
commander captain - Roy refused to
bestow this rank upon him when asked why
he had not been promoted to go I
commented would you have me nominate to
sergeant's a boy who would only be at
his ease as the grand constable in
reflecting upon this time with a 33rd
infantry DeGaulle later made the remark
that the most valuable lesson he had
gotten from his first year in the ranks
was that if you did the exact opposite
of what you were told to do by the
noncommissioned officers you would get
on fairly well he entered the military
academy of socia in autumn of 1910 he
quickly earned reputation as an arrogant
dandy with an air superiority two
nicknames quickly became attached to him
Legrand Shaw and legrasse Pierre this
last title translates as the great
asparagus and was a bear
a reference to his stature at six foot
five inches in height he towered over
virtually everyone that he met one of
his classmates was the future of general
Bette wah commander of French troops in
the 1940s Battle of Norway he remembered
to Gaul as a mediocre students he had
few friends the fact that he graduated
13th out of his class of 211 in 1912
seems to indicate that he was somewhat
more than mediocre it was expected that
a young man with the ambition of the
goal would be chosen to join a cavalry
regiments as that was traditionally the
fastest route to promotion through the
ranks however Charles had already come
to the conclusion that the days of the
horse soldier they were over he believed
that future wars would be won by the
infantry as a result he made the
decision to return to the 33rd infantry
at harass to gold Spenser the next two
years learning the craft of an army
officer it didn't take long for that
lanky officer to make an impression in
the town of harass heads turned when he
passed by with people being captivated
by both his extraordinary height and his
regal bearing yet his rather caustic
cold nature repelled more than his
impressive appearance attracted not long
after de gaulle's arrival at Arras the
33rd received a new commanding officer
Colonel Philippe baton Charles develops
a great deal of respect for Tom in his
memoirs he wrote my first colonel patois
taught me the art of command but always
also impressed with de Gaulle in October
of 1913 he recommended his first
promotion to first lieutenant
[Music]
when war broke out in August of 1914 the
33rd Infantry Regiment as part of the
French fifth Army was deployed to do
know in order to halt the German advance
throughout that region de Gaulle was
immediately into the action with his
first engagements on August the 15th
being the Battle of Dien oh he was
wounded in the knee and sent to the
hospital to recover when he returned to
the regiment in October many of his men
and fellow officers they were dead two
months later he was promoted to
regimental adjutant the thirty third
Infantry Regiment became famous for
their ability to crawl out into no-man's
land in order to spy on the enemy the
intelligence gathered from this work it
wonder called the quad Agora medal in
February 1915 he was promoted to captain
the following month an inconsequential
hand wound would become infected leaving
him out of action for the next four
months during the Battle of Verdun in
March of 1916 the Gaul was wounded in
the left thigh by a bayonet and
subsequently captured after passing out
from the effects of poison gas the Gulf
spent the remainder of the war in a
German prisoner of war camp he attempted
to escape five times he attempted
escaped by hiding in a laundry basket
digging a tunnel digging a hole through
a wall and even posing as a nurse in
order to fool the guards in letters that
he wrote to his parents during his
captivity he expressed his great
frustration that he was unable to
participate in the war effort any longer
he referred to himself as being
cuckolded and fell into a state of
depression following the Armistice in
1918 he was released and returned to his
parents home in Dordogne in the south of
France
[Music]
in early 9020 the goal was posted to
Poland as part of the French military
mission to Poland that he served as an
instructor to the Polish infantry he
served with distinction earning the rank
of major in the Polish army and being
awarded the Distinguished virtuti
militari purlins highest military
decoration he returns of France in 1921
and spent a year as a military history
lecturer at the cell sere academy he
then spent two years studying at the
Ecole Militaire in Paris he graduated
with a grade of a sabia or good enough
and was then posted to the Rhineland
area of Germany which was under French
occupation during the mid 1920s de
Gaulle worked as a ghostwriter for his
old commander at our ass the now marshal
baton in 1926 however the two had a
falling out over a book on the history
of the French soldier that de Gaulle had
ghostwritten called la Sol da in October
of that year he returns the Rhine to
commence his military duties there in
1927 after a dozen years in the army
de Gaulle was promoted to commandant he
was then posted to the occupying forces
at tree Air in Germany at the head of
the 19th Shasu a PA which was a light
infantry battalion de Gaulle was a hard
taskmaster on his soldiers often pushing
them beyond what was reasonable on one
occasion he got into hot water for
throwing a soldier into prison for
exercising his right to appeal to his
Member of Parliament for a transfer to a
less demanding unit even though he had
had a falling out with patrol he called
on his old commander to help get him out
of the mess with the ends of the Allied
occupation the Rhineland in 1929 the
goal was posted to Lebanon and Syria he
served with distinction with his
commanding officer providing him with an
impressive recommendation when he
returned to France in 1931 he then
received a posting to the General
Secretariat of the supreme war council
based in Paris his job description was
as a drafting officer for the next six
years de Gaulle gained valuable
experience in military bureaucracy over
that time he worked with government
officials in drafting bills related to
the military he worked on a bill for the
organization of France during the event
of war but it did not pass the Senate
throughout this period the goal was not
shy about voicing his opinion on the
military preparations that France was
making in the event of another European
war he considered the line of
fortifications known as the
line on which billions of dollars were
being spent to be a wasted effort rather
than focusing on a defensive footing he
contended that the French needed to be
proactive through mechanized warfare
that was fast moving in 1934 he wrote a
book called toward a professional army
in it he outlined his plans for the
future French army with a hundred
thousand men and three thousand tanks in
1937 de Gaulle came a step closer to
realizing this ambition when he was
given commands of the five hundred and
seven tank regiments with this promotion
of the tank as the key to French
infantry success he became a nationally
known figure with people calling him
Colonel motors now just before we get
into his later military career I do want
to tell you about today's sponsor war
thunder there fantastic because they
sponsor longer videos like this and we
can really dive deep into a subject so
war thunder is a realistic free-to-play
combat game and if your fantasy becoming
your own Colonel motors then why not
give it a try it always amazes me when I
hear that there are millions of players
on these online games but then again I
see why it's amazing what games are like
these days you can look at it right now
I mean it looks incredible and it's free
so why not in this game there are over
1200 historically accurate vehicles
there are tanks aircraft ships and just
incredible vehicles from the 1930s
onwards indeed I'm just about to talk
about a French tank the r35 and that's
totally available in war thunder so this
game is available on PC ps4 Xbox one so
join us on the battlefield for free
using the link below doing that supports
this show and it also gets you a free
premium tank or aircraft and three days
of premium time as a bonus just for
registering
and let's get back to it with the French
declaration of war upon Germany in
September of 1939 de Gaulle was put in
command of the fifth Army's five tank
battalions mostly equipped with our 35
light tanks in early 1940 he lobbied for
the position of Secretary General of the
war council the government's top
military advisor but he was passed over
towards the end of march 1940 de Gaulle
was given command of the newly created
4th armored division with the German
attack on May the 10th the 4th armored
they went into action on May the 17th
they encountered the Germans at mon
coeur ney it was a disaster fertig all
with 23 of his 90 tanks being destroyed
by mines anti-tank weapons dive bomber
and ground attack aircraft two days
later his reinforced division was
decimated for a second time despite
being ordered to withdraw he fought on
demanding even more reinforcements even
though this request was denied he
managed to push the Germans back to calm
more but this was only a temporary
respite on May the 20th de Gaulle began
to retreat in the face of the
unstoppable German advance on May the
23rd he was promoted to Brigadier
General on May the 28th the led an
attack on a German bridgehead at
Abbeville which captured some 400
prisoners by the beginning of June the
goal had been recalled to Paris where he
was offered and he accepted the position
of Under Secretary of State for national
defence of war On June the 8th II met
with the army commander-in-chief waggons
who was about to announce the French
surrender when de Gaulle tried to
convince him to fight on Hogan's laughte
despairingly the following day de Gaulle
flew to London where he met British
Prime Minister Winston Churchill for the
first time his attempts to convince
Churchill to put more RAF fighters into
the Battle of France fell on deaf ears
upon his return to Paris he wanted to
defend the city to the last man but
Weyand had other ideas the government
was relocated to tour where a series of
meetings with British officials were
held during these meetings Gauls
fighting resolve impressed the Brits
standing in stark contrast with other
French leaders On June the 6th de Gaulle
was back in London discussing the
logistics of a troop withdrawal to
French North Africa when he returned to
France later that day discovered the
Prime Minister Renault had resigned to
be replaced by marshal
who was intent on signing an armistice
with the Germans
the goal now fled France for London
ahead of the German takeover on June the
18th Churchill offered him airtime on
BBC Radio to address the French people
in the speech the Gaul encouraged his
countrymen to be brave during the
occupation resisting it as best they
could
the next day he gave another broadcast
this time he was more critical of the
baton government denouncing it as
illegitimate on June the 22nd following
the signing of the armistice
de Gaulle took to the BBC again he
denounced the surrender and again
declared the French government
illegitimate On June the 28th the
British government recognized Gaul as
the leader of free France his government
in exile consisted of three Colonels
twelve captains and three battalions of
Legionnaires over the following month
the Gauls main weapon was BBC radio he
would give broadcasts an average of
three times per month denouncing the
occupation government based in Vichy UNS
urging Frenchmen to resist the
occupation the Patong government
sentenced a gold to death in absentia
throughout the war years the gold was
able to slowly build up the Free French
army on April the 21st 1943 he boarded a
plane enroute to Scotland to inspect his
navy the plane almost crashed on takeoff
and it was later found that it had been
sabotage using acid in May of 1943 de
Gaulle moved his headquarters to French
Algiers where he became the head of the
French committee of national liberation
he became involved in the planning for
the d-day invasion although the
Americans and British became
increasingly frustrated with his
insistence that he was the rightful
leader of France he returned to Britain
on June the 4th 1944 whereupon Churchill
asked him to address the French people
over BBC Radio in anticipation of the
Allied invasion
however the script he was given did not
acknowledge him as the legitimate
interim ruler of France and so he
refused to deliver it
[Music]
in the wake of the d-day invasion of
June the 6th 1944 the Free French army
under the leadership of general de
l'autre tossing gear
landed in southern France and were
instrumental in pushing back the Germans
On June the 14th de Gaulle returns to
France
traveling through newly liberated Norman
towns he was well received by the
townspeople he established the capital
of free France in May Owens then set off
to Rome where he met the newly installed
Italian government from there he flew to
Washington for his first meeting with
President Roosevelt the visit was a
strange one with Roosevelt not providing
the usual privileges of a visiting head
of state the goal pushed for the Allies
to privatize the liberation of Paris
fearing a communist takeover but there
was no strategic priority for the Allies
to focus on Paris still through de
gaulle's insistence supreme Allied
commander Dwight Eisenhower agreed that
Paris would be prioritized out of
humanitarian and symbolic need he also
permitted the Free French army to be the
first to enter the French capital on
Saturday August the 26th de Gaulle
entered Paris in a triumphant march down
the shops Elysees as the procession made
its way towards notre-dame Cathedral it
caimans a machine-gun fire from Vichy
government militia a BBC reporter who
was present noted de Gaulle's demeanor
as he confidently strode forward stating
general de Gaulle walked straight ahead
into what appeared to me to be a hail of
fire but he went straight ahead without
hesitation his shoulders flung back and
walked right down the center aisle even
while the bullets were pouring about him
it was the most extraordinary example of
courage I have ever seen upon reaching
the Great Hall of the hotel de ville de
Gaulle spoke before an ecstatic crowd
his inspiring message included these
words Paris Paris outraged Paris broken
Paris martyred but Paris liberated
liberated by itself liberated by its
people with the assistance of the armies
of France with a sport and assistance of
the whole of France the enemy is
faltering but he is not yet beaten he is
still on our soil it will not suffice
that we with the assistance of our dear
and admirable allies will have chased
him from our home in order to be
satisfied after what has happened we
want to enter his territory as is
fitting as conquerors it is for this
revenge this venge
this justice that we will continue to
fight until the last day until the day
of total and complete victory with his
bold and triumphant entry into Paris to
goal won the respect of the world in the
days that followed the Allied leaders
made statements recognizing his
government as the legitimate ruler of
France the provisional government of the
French Republic was established on
September the 10th 1944 to go then set
out on a tour of the country in each
city freely mixed with the crowds with
no regard for his own safety towards the
end of 1944 legal purge was established
to punish traitors during the occupation
and removed the last vestiges of the
Vichy government over the course of the
purge around 2,000 people were sentenced
to death the goal commuted around a
thousand of those sentences in May 1945
the Germans surrendered signing an
armistice with France in Berlin however
on the very day the victory in Europe
was proclaimed May the 8th rats broke
out in French Tunisia 12 days later the
French artillery fired on demonstrators
in Damascus leaving hundreds dead this
events caused the ever testy
relationship between de Gaulle and
Churchill to reach a low ebb Churchill
commented that the goal was a great
danger for peace and to Great Britain
[Music]
[Applause]
the French Constituent Assembly
unanimously elected goals head of the
French governments on November the 13th
1945 after two months of struggles with
communists within his government he
abruptly resigned and formed the right
wing rally of the French people he
believed that his popularity as a war
hero would propel him back to power but
this gamble it didn't pay off after
three years in the political wilderness
he left the party and politics behind
[Music]
giggle then retired from public life to
write his memoirs in 1958 a crisis in
Algeria brought him back to politics the
Algerian National Liberation Front it
was waging a war for independence and
the goal was seen as the kind of strong
national leader who could quash it he
returned to the presidency and proceeded
to use brutal force to put down the
rebels but these harsh methods they
backfired the Algerian people were
driven further towards independence
while around the world there was
condemnation against the French
government under intense pressure from
within his own country and abroad to
goal finally granted independence to all
13 French African colonies in 1962 as
the cold war develops the goal advocated
the developments of a French nuclear
arsenal the country became the world's
fourth nuclear power in February of 1960
three years later de Gaulle refused to
sign the partial test ban treaty in 1965
he was reelected for a second seven-year
term as French president he ran his
government and his country with a
heavy-handed dogmatic style that often
drew criticism in early 1969 he called
for a nationwide referendum on the
reform of the Senate when his proposal
was rejected by the people he offered
his resignation following through on a
televised promise made two days before
the referendum
at the age of 78 having lived an
extraordinarily full public life the
goal retired to write an updated version
of his memoirs he died suddenly on
November the 9th 1970 or watching TV he
complained to his wife that he was
feeling pain in his neck and then
collapsed to the ground he died within
minutes the autopsy revealed that he had
suffered from a ruptured blood vessel
the funeral of Charles DeGaulle on
November the 12th 1970 it was the
largest in French history today he ranks
alongside Napoleon as among the greatest
of French leaders so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below also
don't forget to check out our sponsor
for this episode war thunder you'll find
them all linked to below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]